Professor Robert
Shiller: I believe that we
still have on,
for Friday, Stephen Schwarzman.
He said he would do it.
I always worry about people who
have such important businesses
because some big deal may become
in crisis or something;
people like that have trouble
sometimes adhering to a
schedule.
As far as I know we're getting
him, so I hope that you will all
be able to come this Friday,
here, at the usual time.
If there's any problem with his
appearing I will email you.
As you know,
Stephen Schwarzman is a
graduate of Yale College and
he's one of the great stories of
our century.
He created just about the
biggest private equity firm from
scratch in 1985 and I guess they
just went public and they have a
huge market cap.
They're comparable to one of
the biggest old line investment
banks in New York.
He just--he and Peter
Peterson--just created it so I
think it will be very
interesting to hear him.
Again, you'll have a chance to
question him about what he's
done.
I put on the reading list
The New Yorker article
that's out right now.
Well actually,
I guess it came out a couple of
weeks ago, but it's up on our
syllabus.
I think I might want to take it
down before he comes.
I'm going to turn--I'm going to
reflect on this because he may
not be pleased with the article.
It's a very hard-hitting
critical article.
He had to be a tough
businessman to arrive where he
is.
The New Yorker article
talks about the price of his
condo--or co-op--in New York,
which set some record,
and so they tell things like
that.
I was just yesterday in London
and people like to gossip about
things like that.
The limo driver was driving me
to the airport and was pointing
out the scenes in London.
He said, you know that building?
Some Arab Sheikh just paid one
hundred million pounds for that
apartment--that penthouse
apartment--in that building and
the same Sheikh is ordering a
Airbus for his--one of these big
Airbus airplanes--for his
personal plane and he's having
it plated with gold leaf.
Did you hear this story?
Does anyone--is this true?
This limo driver told me this
yesterday;
he said it's going to cost him
five hundred million pounds or
something like that to do this.
These are gossip.
The real substance is what the
man does--or woman does--for the
world.
So, I gleaned here a list of
some of the charities
that--Stephen Schwarzman is a
major philanthropist.
He set up something called The
Blackstone Foundation from the
Blackstone Group and he's a
major donor or collaborator with
the Frick Collection,
The Whitney Museum,
Phoenix House,
The Red Cross,
The Inner City Scholarship
Fund,
New York City Outward Bound,
and the Asia Society.
I think that's the real thing
we should talk about,
not the size of his penthouse.
So, I might try to find a more
even-handed account and put that
up on the website.
Incidentally,
there's sort of a resemblance
between him and David Swensen in
the–well,
first of all,
they're both phenomenally
successful, but they both are
emphasizing alternative
investments.
They're not straight-laced
old-fashioned;
they're willing to take
experiments.
I think he should be very
interesting;
that's Friday at 9.
I want to talk about the stock
market today and I thought I
would keep it more or less basic
because I think--I want to
emphasize basic concepts.
A lot I'm going to talk about
is Modigliani-Miller but I'm not
going to get too deep into it,
maybe in your review sections
you can get more technical.
I'm going to just talk about it
in the very intuitive,
direct terms.
What are stocks?
I think the idea of a stock
must have been invented
independently at many times in
history.
The word "shares" is the
fundamental word.
Suppose you are starting a
business with somebody--it could
be at any time in
history--Babylonia or
something--this must have
happened.
A group of people starts a
business and they say,
let's divide up the proceeds.
That's very direct, isn't it?
If we're all working together
we divide up the proceeds.
That means we're allocating
shares.
Now, I don't know how far back
it goes but it must be that in
ancient times some people would
say,
all right you're going to be
doing more work or you're
contributing more to this
enterprise,
we'll give you a bigger share
of the profits.
That's so basic,
it must have happened a million
times and that's the basic idea
of the stock market.
All it is is that we've got it
much more high-flown and much
more legalized than--the basic
idea is that you have to have
shares in something--a
business--and the idea goes back
clearly to ancient Rome.
Let's consider a business as
sort of a person who is owned,
like a slave,
who is owned by other people.
In law, the word "person"
doesn't mean what you think it
means.
There's--in law,
a "natural person" is you and
me;
people, real flesh and blood
individuals are called natural
persons.
But when we say "person," it
also--that's more general--it
also includes corporation.
The word "corporation" comes
from the Latin,
corpus, meaning body,
so it's an embodiment.
We create an entity that,
in the eyes of the law,
is like an individual.
It may be owned by other
individuals but it has its own
rights and responsibilities as
if it were a person.
In ancient Rome,
corporations were called
publicani--that's Latin;
the publicani were
companies like we have today.
According to the research of
Ulrike Malmendier at Stanford,
she thinks that the stock
market in ancient Rome was done
on the street--on the Roman
Forum--and she can tell you
where.
When you go to Rome,
you can walk and see what's
left of their stock market.
It never flourished really
until relatively modern times.
The idea, of course,
is that we have a legal
entity--a corporation--that
issues shares that are either
given to people or purchased by
people and the idea is that
shares represent contributions.
You give shares to someone who
is contributing to the
enterprise.
You can--when you set up a
corporation there are different
kinds of relationships that
people might have with a
corporation.
One of them is as a shareholder
and the shareholder gets a
share--is entitled to a
share--of the profits.
There are also employees who
get wages and that's very
different.
They have a labor contract that
specifies how much they will
get.
Then you have debtors and other
people with other relationships.
The fundamental one is the
shareholder because the
shareholder owns the
corporation.
As it's evolved in modern
times, the corporation has a
charter or bylaws.
When you create a corporation
you write up a contract,
which specifies the rules of
the corporation;
it's like a constitution for
the corporation.
Also, the law of the state in
which the corporation is
chartered also puts restrictions
on what can be in the bylaws.
Notably, it's typically
required that it's one share,
one vote and that there's a--it
would be also required that
there be an annual meeting--at
least once a year,
a shareholder meeting--and then
the shareholders can vote on
relevant issues.
One of the most important
issues then is to elect a board
of directors.
The state law probably requires
that a corporation have a board
of directors,
but it's also something that
can be defined at the time that
you create the corporation in
the bylaws.
It's not something you can do
just whatever you want.
State law has requirements for
the board of directors and--I'm
just going to talk in very basic
terms.
The usual structure is one
shareholder, one vote.
At the annual meeting,
the shareholders can come and
elect a board and the board then
is in charge of the company.
The board hires the president
or chief executive officer and
other top officers of the
company and they serve as
employees of the board.
The theory is that the
shareholders are in control
because they elect the board and
the board hires the president
and it's democratic.
I'm going to come back to it;
it doesn't always work out as
perfectly as you want.
Now there's
basically–there are
important distinctions between
two kinds of corporations.
There's for-profit and
non-profit.
I've been describing a
for-profit corporation,
which is the usual variety.
Non-profit corporations will
also have a board of directors
but they will not have any
shareholders.
There's a fundamental
difference in the charter and
the way the government reacts to
them.
The non-profit organization or
corporation is set up to advance
some cause and it is not owned
by anyone.
The share price,
you could say,
is identically zero.
Actually, you can't say what
the share price is because there
are zero shares and they have a
zero price,
so the value of the price per
share is zero over zero and you
can't define it.
Yale University is a non-profit
corporation;
the price of a share in Yale
University is undefined--it's
zero over zero.
It has a board that runs it,
but the board is not liable to
shareholder vote.
Well actually,
we have some voting among
alumni I guess,
but it's not a for-profit
corporation.
I'm going to be talking about
for-profit.
Now, the critical thing to
understand about a corporation
is that in order to value a
share in a corporation you
absolutely have to know the
number of shares outstanding.
If I own one thousand shares in
a company, what does that mean?
It doesn't mean anything until
you know how many shares are
outstanding because if I own one
thousand shares and then you
look it up and find out how many
shares are outstanding--there
are one thousand--you say,
hey I own the whole company.
It's mine if I own one thousand
shares and there are one
thousand outstanding.
What if you own one thousand
shares and there are ten million
outstanding?
Well, then that means that you
own one ten-thousandth of the
company.
Did I divide right?
That's a very important lesson
to keep in mind.
People don't usually know how
many shares are outstanding in
the company that they invest in.
That's because,
in a sense, they're trusting to
analysts.
Ultimately, analysts are
supposed to keep track of this.
When they look at the price of
a company, how do we know
whether the price at which
you're buying is reasonable?
They must be looking at some
measure of the value of the
company and dividing by the
number of shares and then that
gives them some idea of what the
share is worth.
But it's absolutely
essential--so the shares only
mean something as a relation to
their total number of shares.
Companies routinely do what are
called "splits."
They may do a two-for-one split;
that means, if you held one
thousand shares you get a letter
saying, congratulations you now
own two thousand shares.
Don't be too jubilant because
when they do a split they do it
to every single shareholder.
So, you now have two thousand
shares, but now there are twenty
million shares outstanding in
the company so the ratio is
unchanged.
You might ask,
well why do they do splits?
Well, it's just to keep the
numbers--there's actually not a
very good reason to do splits.
There's no reason not to do
splits either because it's just
changing the units of
measurement.
But typically,
in the United States,
they do splits to keep the
price of a share somewhere in
the $20 to $40 range;
there's interesting literature
on why they do that.
Maybe it's a tradition,
maybe it's to keep the value
kind of in a familiar range or a
small--they don't want them to
get too expensive because people
can't--small investors can't
afford them anymore.
Who knows, but the point is
it's different in different
countries.
So the total number of shares
is almost--the tendency to do
splits is a cultural thing;
it's of no real significance.
Warren Buffett doesn't do
splits with his Berkshire
Hathaway and there are other
companies that--I guess Google
doesn't do splits,
isn't that right?
Is that right or are you saying
no?
Actually, I don't remember,
but they haven't done one yet.
What is the price per share,
do you know?
This is getting a little
high--$550 a share is kind of
high because most people will
buy--this is part of our
tradition.
Most people will buy shares in
what's called "round blocks,"
that's a hundred shares.
So, if it's $550,
that makes $55,000 for a one
round lot.
I can't multiply while I'm
standing up.
Most companies do splits
because that might close
the--you might have been
thinking about investing in
Google but you could still--you
could just say,
I want to buy ten shares or
five shares and the broker will
do it for you,
but they might charge a higher
commission.
That's the lesson.
There's a term--I should write
some of my terms down--a very
important term in finance and
that's "dilution."
If the company increases the
number of shares through a split
that is not dilution because it
doesn't really mean anything.
When you do a split,
you're changing the number of
shares for everybody,
so it can have no effect on the
ratio for anybody;
it's just purely appearance.
Dilution occurs when the
company changes the number of
shares asymmetrically--not
changing it for everybody.
The typical example of dilution
is: the board of directors has
hired a CEO for the company and
they want to motivate the CEO.
They can pay the CEO a salary
or they can give shares to the
CEO--that's quite standard
because they feel that that
makes the CEO a shareholder.
It's like another form of
compensation and that
compensation might have
different attractiveness,
so they give the person a
package--both a salary and some
shares.
You see, if they give the--if
they merely give shares to the
CEO without increasing your
shares,
then you are being diluted
because it's raising the total
and it's reducing the ratio.
Now, if a company sells shares,
it issues new shares--it can do
that at any time.
When you start a company you
might have had--maybe when Peter
Peterson and Stephen Schwarzman
founded The Blackstone Group
they gave each of them five
hundred shares--I'm just making
that up--but obviously there's
going to be more shareholders as
time comes in.
One thing that people can do to
get in is to buy shares.
If the company issues new
shares by selling them to the
public, it's not obviously
dilution.
Of course it's lowering your
share of the company,
but offsetting this is that the
company is taking in money from
the person who bought the shares
and so it doesn't dilute you.
Well, you could say it dilutes
it but it doesn't lower the
price of your investment,
in general.
It could, depending on a lot of
factors.
Dilution occurs--the term
specifically refers to changes
in a number of shares that
affect, adversely,
existing shareholders.
Another common term is a "stock
dividend."
Well first of all,
I should talk about dividends.
The stock market--I was going
to talk about stock dividends,
but I better talk about
dividends first.
In for-profit companies,
people are investing in the
company for profit.
How do they get the profit?
Well, the company--the board of
directors--decides if and when
to pay dividends to the
shareholders and then the law of
the state would say that they
must treat them all equally.
They made some money and now
they want to take it out and
spend it.
They have to do it equally to
all shareholders;
that's called paying a dividend.
They can do it on rare
occasions, or they can do it
whenever they feel like it,
or they can do it regularly;
it's often done quarterly.
When I set up a company--Case
Shiller Weiss,
Inc.--typical of young start up
companies, we didn't pay a
dividend.
We gave shares to almost all of
our employees as part of their
compensation and we hoped that
would motivate them and make
them feel a part of the company
but we never paid them a
dividend.
I remember one time I was
talking to our CEO and he said,
you know maybe we should pay at
least one dividend because our
employees are forgetting that
they own these shares.
So, we paid one dividend and I
don't know how much excitement
it generated,
but that's the--
Student: Does this mean
that share price will drop by $2
after a $2 dividend?
Immediately after the payout
dividend, the share--the price
of the share should go down,
right?
Professor Robert
Shiller: Yes,
he's asking after a firm pays a
dividend that should lower
the--you were asking whether it
should lower the price of a
share.
Yes, you are absolutely right.
If the company pays out money,
the value of the company should
have just gone down by the
amount they paid out,
but the number of shares hasn't
changed.
That means that the price of
each share should decline by the
amount they paid out divided by
the number of shares.
There's a term for that--they
call it going ex-dividend.
So the company--it used to be
you could look on--you can still
see this.
Some of these are still listed
on The New York Stock Exchange
page;
on the day that a stock goes
ex-dividend, they'll have a
little "x" by its price.
The reason they put that there
is so that people don't get
alarmed.
A lot of people watch the price
of their share everyday--some
people get neurotic about
it--and then suddenly it drops
by $2 a share and they say,
oh my God I'm worried.
They call up their broker and
say, what's wrong?
Then the broker has to explain,
no didn't you see the "x"
there?
It just went ex-dividend,
so it doesn't mean anything.
The "ex-dividend date" is not
the date that you actually
received the dividend,
but it's called the ex-dividend
date, which the company decides
on that date anyone who was a
stockholder of record gets the
dividend and the guy after that,
you don't get that dividend.
That's an important--this
really does happen,
stocks really do drop in price
on ex-dividend date.
Now incidentally,
that's an interesting question
that you bring up,
because--should I pay any
attention to dividend dates as
an investor?
The answer is generally not
because if you buy the stock
before it goes ex-dividend,
you get--you have to pay a
higher price,
but you get the dividend.
If you wait until the next day,
you pay a lower price but you
don't get the dividend.
Unless there are some tax
effects, which might matter--and
taxes always complicate
things--but disregarding tax
effects,
it doesn't matter which you do.
In fact, there's a rule,
FINRA, which licenses
stockbrokers,
tells their people,
you must not sell dividends;
they're referring to a bad
practice that some unscrupulous
stockbrokers occasionally do.
They'll tell someone,
hurry up and buy this stock
because it's going to go
ex-dividend.
If you buy it today--if you
wait, you won't get the
dividend.
That's misleading because it
really doesn't matter when you
buy the stock,
so you're not supposed to,
as a broker,
sell dividends.
That doesn't mean dividends
don't matter.
Ultimately, they're a reason
why you own a stock.
This gets back--People are
accustomed to getting dividend
checks in the mail.
If you own stock--we don't get
them in the mail anymore because
you own it through some
brokerage account and you get it
on a website.
You used to get checks in the
mail;
now you go on a website and
you'll see that your dividends
are credited to your account,
but money is growing in your
account as companies pay out
dividends.
I was going to talk about a
stock dividend and I started to
do that.
Sometimes companies will
announce that they are paying
not a cash dividend,
but they're paying a stock
dividend.
They'll say,
we are pleased to announce that
we are paying a dividend in new
shares issued today by the
company equal to 5% of your
existing shares--so it's a 5%
dividend--congratulations.
Is that a good thing?
How excited should you be to
get the letter saying your
company has paid you a stock
dividend?
Any ideas on that?
Well, you should be absolutely
unexcited because it doesn't
mean anything;
if they were giving you extra
shares and just you alone,
that would be great--that would
be good.
The whole essence of a stock
dividend is that they're paying
it to every shareholder in the
same proportion,
so every one hundred shares
becomes one hundred and five
shares;
so you know that that has no
meaning to me.
All that matters is the ratio:
how many shares I own divided
by the number of shares
outstanding.
If they both go up by the same
proportion, then numerator and
denominator go up by the same
amount, so there's no change.
Then you might ask,
why in the world do companies
issue stock dividends anyway,
what's the point?
Are they trying to confuse or
fool somebody?
Well, there are different views
on that.
One of them is yes,
they are trying to confuse and
fool somebody.
If they don't have money to pay
the dividend they can always do
a stock dividend.
On the other hand,
some people say,
well that would backfire.
If they're going to pay stock
dividends and try to fool us,
what's going to happen?
The price of a share is going
to fall on that day.
When you pay out stock
dividends you would think that
now there are more shares,
everyone divides by the larger
number of shares,
and the value of the company
goes down;
it's not going to work to pay a
stock dividend.
So, the more enlightened view
is, corporations only pay a
stock dividend when they have
some good news to announce.
Typically, they'll write a
letter saying,
congratulations we have great
news!
We have some new breakthrough
and in celebration of this we're
going to pay everyone a 5% stock
dividend.
Now, they are hoping that the
price doesn't fall because
they're announcing it with news
and,
in a sense, issuing the stock
dividend is just a way to make
it dramatic.
Now incidentally,
in a for-profit
corporation--this is how to
understand this,
this is a concept that is
enshrined in law.
In a for-profit corporation,
the purpose of the entity is
defined as profit for the
shareholders.
Now, in some countries and in
some jurisdictions the law might
not be entirely clear on that;
they might say there are other
stakeholders.
But, in the purest form--and
this is the form that we have in
the United States--the company
exists for the shareholders.
They're the ones--there are
other people who have contracts
with the company,
like the employees,
but the employees are not
shareholders;
they are receiving salary or
something else.
The important thing for the
corporation is to live up to any
promises it made.
It has to live up to its
promises.
The purpose of the corporation
is the shareholders.
This is a capitalist idea that
might sometimes sound wrong.
You might say,
why should a company exist for
the shareholders?
Well, the concept here is that
it's a good business model.
People do need money and they
go into business to make money;
so let's make it clear,
that's what the company is
going to do.
It has to behave in an
honorable way for everyone;
it has to live up to its
contract.
But the company generally
doesn't give to charity;
it doesn't contribute to
political campaigns;
it shouldn't be,
ideally, doing any of those
things.
It should be trying to get
money back to the shareholders.
If you ever serve on a board of
directors--this is the thing
that I want you to remember
because many of you will serve
on boards of directors.
When you sign on to a job on
the board, you are signing on to
a solemn responsibility and that
responsibility is to treat all
shareholders equally and fairly
and make money for them.
Then you're not supposed to
ever do anything that's not
honest or not living up to
contracts,
but your purpose is only one
purpose: it's the shareholder.
When you serve on a board,
you are in a fiduciary role;
you are there to protect
shareholders and that's the
concept.
It's for-profit and the theory
that we have in capitalist
countries is that this is a good
model.
There are non-profits,
fine, but we--a lot of the
stuff that has to be done for an
economy is only going to get
done through for-profit
corporations.
So let's make it clear--let's
make it unambiguous--people who
are on boards or are managers of
these companies,
they can give their personal
money to charities but they
themselves are obligated to make
money.
It's not a vice.
This is the concept that is in
the law and the reason we have
it in the law is that it works
to produce prosperity and to
produce the things we need,
like clothes,
medical service,
homes, whatever.
So that's why we do it and
there's no shame in pursuing
profits and getting it out to
your shareholders.
Now ultimately,
the purpose of investing in a
share is to get the dividends;
that's the whole named purpose
of the corporation.
I might add though that there
are other ways that--I may have
said that too narrowly.
Traditionally,
you buy stocks to get
dividends;
that's the reason.
I want to be careful about
qualifying that.
First of all,
a lot of people don't seem to
even grasp that basic point that
you buy stocks for the
dividends.
A lot of people think,
I will buy stocks.
But why do people buy stocks?
They'll buy stocks because they
think price is going to go up
and make them a lot of money.
They can sell it at an
advantage.
That's what most people think,
right?
Do I buy stocks for dividends?
Some people don't even know
what a dividend is,
they just think of stock as
something whose price goes up.
It doesn't make sense to think
that the price of anything would
go up if that's all there is to
it.
Why would people pay any price
for stocks if there weren't some
way to get money out?
The ultimate thing is the
dividend;
the dividends,
even though a lot of people
forget the dividends and don't
realize how important they are,
they are actually the driving
force.
I wanted to just show you a
plot that you already saw in
your--if you looked on the
spreadsheet that I had up.
This is the stock market for
the United States;
it's the Standard &
Poor Composite.
In 1957, they reformulated it
and they called it the Standard
& Poor 500,
but I'm using their long
theories, back to 1871,
so I can't call it the 500;
I'm calling it the Composite.
What this is is the price of a
portfolio of shares in U.S.
companies.
It's kind of like the average
price of a share adjusted for
splits because you don't want
the--obviously when they do a
two-for-one split,
the price falls in half and
that's meaningless,
so you want to correct for
splits.
S&P corrects for splits and
follows the price of a share.
Now unfortunately,
the same companies are not
around--the companies that we
had in 1871, hardly any of them
even exist anymore.
What they do is they're pricing
a portfolio up here and they
keep substituting in new ones.
There's an index committee that
keeps bringing in new shares
when new companies become
important;
they try to get the 500
representative of the most
companies in the world--in the
U.S.
You can see that's what the
price has done.
There are also the earnings per
share.
What are earnings per share?
Earnings are something that
accountants have generated and
they've been doing it all the
way back to 1871--it's a
venerable concept;
it's how much money the company
made this year,
if it's annual earnings.
The price of a share is the
price of the ownership of that
earnings' stream,
forever.
If I buy a share I'm in with
everyone else who owns the
company and I have a claim on
the earnings' stream,
but the earnings' stream is a
year-by-year thing.
It just tells you how well they
did in that given year.
You can see that the stock
market has been more volatile
than the earnings and the price
of a share is many times higher
than the earnings per share.
So, typically the ratio of
price-to-earnings has been about
fifteen.
That means that people will pay
up front for about fifteen
years' earnings.
Earnings and dividends are
different;
earnings is the money that the
company made in a given year.
How do they know what they made?
That's a complicated thing that
accountants figure out and
accountants find it difficult to
define the earnings of a
company,
but they do something and they
come up with a number.
It may surprise the company
directors how much we made or
how little we made according to
the accountants.
The dividend is something much
more concrete.
This is what they actually send
out--this is cash sent out to
shareholders.
"Earnings" is kind of a
theoretical concept that
accountants work on and it can
go up and down depending on
adjustments they make.
They might decide that we have
some investment over there that
we just lost money on and we
should take a write off for
that.
The management might say,
well what do you mean we didn't
lose any money this year?
But the accountants thought we
did.
So that's earnings.
Dividends is very concrete,
it's what they send out.
Here is the price-earnings
ratio for the U.S.
stock market from 1881 to the
present--this is also on that
spreadsheet that you have on the
website.
You can see that I'm saying
about fifteen--fifteen times
earnings is typical,
but we're in a high
price-to-earnings scenario now.
It goes up and down depending
on the outlook for earnings and
maybe other factors.
The red line is long-term
interest rates,
but I won't talk more about
that right now.
The earnings is a measure of
the value of the company and
typically they've been valued at
something like fifteen times
earnings.
When the price-earnings ratio
gets high like it did in 1929
people get antsy.
They thought,
oh my God, the price earnings
ratio is thirty-five.
Again, this is price divided by
ten-year earnings,
not one-year earnings.
This is what I do.
We had an extraordinarily high
price-to-earnings ratio
representing a lot of optimism
in the '20s for the stock market
and then it corrected and went
abruptly downward--that was The
Great Depression.
We had a similar,
even higher price-to-earnings
ratio of about forty-six at the
peak in 2000 and it corrected
way down.
The price reflects--really,
when you buy a share of a
company you own it forever.
You will be--you are entitled
to receiving the dividends that
are paid out of earnings for the
rest of your life and you can
give it to your children and
maybe in two hundred years from
now it'll be worth a lot;
probably not, but it might be.
It probably won't even in exist
in fifty years but it will be
bought by some other company and
it will still have value and
will still be going up.
That's the price-earnings ratio.
The earnings,
you understand,
are kind of a theoretical
concept but dividend is the
money that we send out.
How does the company decide on
dividends?
That's again up to the board to
decide or they can set up a
committee on the board that
would decide,
but ultimately,
that's a major decision to send
out dividends.
Typically, young companies do
not send out dividends.
If you set up a company,
you don't want to pay a
dividend for a while because you
need the money and you're
reinvesting it in the company
and people will understand.
They don't expect to get their
money out of an investment right
away.
As a company matures,
then they typically feel that
it's time to pay a dividend.
The S&P 500 is 500
companies, who are major
companies, so these tend to be
mature companies and they tend
to be in the dividend-paying
stage.
The question then is--the
payout ratio is dividends over
earnings, I say Div/E.
I have the payout ratio for the
United States;
that's the payout ratio going
back to 1871.
There are some spikes up like,
for example,
in--what year--that was 1921
maybe--this year,
this is 1932 or 1933--the
companies were paying out 160%
of their earnings as dividends.
You might say,
well what's going on here?
It was The Depression.
What was actually happening
was, The Depression was killing
these companies;
they weren't making any money,
but they didn't want to cut
their dividends because they
were afraid that if they cut the
dividend people would be upset.
They're trying--maybe they did
cut it but they didn't cut it
too much, so that means that
they were paying out more than
they were earning.
That's what typically happens
in these spikes;
it was a crisis.
Now, there's also a trend
downward.
They used to pay out typically
like 80% of their earnings but
it's been gradually going
downward and now it's down to
like 40%.
That's a cultural thing,
I would say;
it's that companies now are
wanting to keep the money.
It may have to do with the fact
that people today don't seem to
be as focused on dividends and
so that means that companies are
more able to reinvest earnings
and not pay.
This is the dividend-price
ratio back to 1871.
Back in the late nineteenth
century the dividend price ratio
was typically 5%.
I think it was clearer in those
days.
In terms of just general
investing culture--and we're
behavioral in our attitude--it
was clearer that you bought a
stock to get a dividend.
Stocks were kind of different
in those days.
They were more like railroads
or steel companies and it was
just understood.
If someone were recommending
you a stock, you'd first say,
what is its dividend?
And if someone said,
it's 4%, you'd say,
well that's kind of meager,
I want a better dividend than
that.
Now, people don't seem to be
focused on them.
In another sense,
they're more willing to entrust
the money back to the board of
directors to decide on when and
whether to pay dividends.
Now the other thing is,
there are other ways to get
money out of a company without
paying a dividend and one of
them is stock repurchase.
There's also liquidation.
Let me mention liquidation or
sale of company.
I'll talk about this--the
company doesn't ever have to pay
a dividend.
All it can do is keep piling in
the money and accumulating it
and then someone will buy the
whole company and then all of
the shareholders will be bought
out at a termination date.
That's one way that a--but
often, when companies are bought
out, they don't give them cash
they give them shares in the
acquiring company.
So, then you would be relying
on getting dividends from the
acquiring company.
I don't emphasize this cash
sale of a company,
but it does happen sometimes.
The other thing that a company
can do to get money out is share
repurchase--a stock repurchase
or a share repurchase.
It's perfectly--this sometimes
surprises people when they first
think about it.
You, as an individual,
can call up your broker and
say, I want to buy Google
shares.
But Larry Paige at Google can
call up a broker--he better get
the board's permission--somebody
at Google can call up a broker
and make the same statement:
we want to buy Google shares.
You might say,
well how can Google buy Google?
"Why not?"
is the answer.
Why shouldn't Google buy Google
shares?
Then you might--well let me ask
you this, what would happen if
Google decided to buy up all of
its shares?
Could that happen?
I'm the CEO of Google and I
call the broker and I say,
how many shares are
outstanding?
Like 100,000,000 or
some–no,
it wouldn't be 100,000,000--we
know the price is $500 a
share--well, I could figure it
out more or less.
The answer is,
you--let me put it this way.
Let me see if this will help
you understand.
Suppose Larry Paige calls up
and says, I'd like to buy all of
the Google shares,
and the broker says,
alright I'll get them for you.
Then he comes back and says,
I managed to get all but one
hundred shares and there's this
one guy--this Yale student--who
owns one hundred shares of
Google stock and I'm having
trouble getting him to sell.
So, the broker calls you up and
says, Google wants to buy all of
its shares--I'm being silly
here.
What do you say to the broker
then?
So, the broker calls you up and
says, you're the last guy,
you have the last one hundred
shares in Google and Google
wants to buy them and we'll give
you $500 a share.
So what do you say?
You say no.
Actually, I have a better
thing, you say,
call Larry Paige and tell him
he's fired because I realize I
own the company.
If I own the last one hundred
shares, it's all mine;
I don't have to take any--I can
do whatever I want.
The last shareholder--so a
company can't buy all of its
shares but it can buy some of
its shares and that's another
way to get money out of the
company.
It's a little different if they
buy--suppose you own a hundred
shares and they declare a 5%
cash dividend,
then you get $5.
But what if the company buys
back 5% of its shares?
What happens then?
Well, the company is still
paying out money in the same
amount total,
but it's coming out in a
different form;
it's coming as a share
repurchase.
It's changing the number of
shares outstanding,
so the value of the company
declines by the same amount;
it has to, as if they had just
paid a dividend.
If they're sending out money,
the value of the company has to
go down by whatever they sent
out.
With share repurchase,
the number of shares goes down,
and if they don't do share
repurchase the number of shares
doesn't go down.
So in a sense,
it's all the same to me as a
shareholder whether they pay
dividends or they repurchase
shares.
I don't know how clear that all
was;
let me just write this down.
This idea has a name.
Two authors,
both who won the Nobel Prize in
finance, Franco--and I know I
was his advisee in my PhD,
so I learned how to pronounce
his
name–Modigliani--because
in Italian you don't pronounce
the "g,"
although I tend to say
Modigliani just to be
understood--and Merton Miller.
Modigliani is one of the
authors of your textbook along
with Fabozzi.
Modigliani and Miller wrote a
famous article arguing
that--what I just said--I just
tried to say it in very
intuitive terms.
They said, dividend policy is
irrelevant.
Although, they do put it in a
qualifier that it could matter
for tax reasons.
In fact, you have to put that
qualifier on just about anything
you say in finance because the
tax system is infinitely complex
and every country has different
taxes,
different states have different
taxes.
There's nothing you can say
boldly in finance if you allow
taxes.
Well, let's just disregard
When Modigliani--this sounds
like a very strong proposition
about dividend irrelevance.
What they're saying is that of
course lots of things that a
board of directors decides to do
are not irrelevant;
it's highly relevant to the
future of the company.
But real things matter,
like if the company decides to
build that new plant in Akron.
That matters for the company
because if the plant works out
to be a success,
then the company will do well.
They're spending money on
concrete, and bricks,
and machinery,
and they could be doing that
wisely or unwisely and that's
beyond finance to evaluate.
What Modigliani and Miller
said, if it's pure dividend
policy, then it is totally
irrelevant;
it means nothing,
so companies can do whatever
they please--I don't care.
You, as a stockholder--I don't
care what they do.
The reason Modigliani and
Miller said that is that they
were thinking that if the
dividend policy is going to be
changed without changing any of
the activities of the firm,
keeping it a purely financial
change, then it must be that
they're switching from dividends
to stock repurchase or stock
repurchase to dividends.
You see, you can keep the
operations the same whether or
not you pay a dividend,
if choosing not to pay a
dividend means substituting
stock repurchase for dividend.
So I'm going to build that
plant in Akron,
whether I pay a dividend or
not, because if I need to cut my
dividend in order to get the
money to build the plant I would
also be cutting my stock
repurchase.
One way or the other it
doesn't--it all comes out to the
same thing.
Let me put it in the simplest
way.
I think the simplest way to
understand Modigliani-Miller
proposition is the following:
imagine that we,
as a board, decided to pay a
dividend of $5 a share.
Let's talk in the old days
about sending checks out,
alright?
We're going to send a letter to
all our shareholders and say,
we have decided to pay a $5
dividend and so you're about to
approve this at the meeting.
We approve a letter--the
letter's going to say,
we're making money here's your
dividend check.
Then someone says,
hey why don't we just change
it?
Why don't we say the same $5
check is included but,
in the letter,
let's say something different?
Let's say this is a repurchase
of some of your shares at market
price, sending the same check,
so what's the difference?
Well, I'll ask you,
what difference does it make?
Suppose you get a letter from
your company saying,
congratulations here's a $5
dividend and here's a check for
$5 if you owned one share.
Or the company says,
congratulations we're
repurchasing 2% of your shares
and here's a check for $5 to pay
you for those shares.
And by the way,
we're doing that with all
shares.
Well, if you think about it,
it doesn't make any difference
to me.
It doesn't matter what that
letter says--I can crumple it up
and throw it in the wastebasket.
I don't--I want the $5 check.
If they're paying me by sending
money and calling it a dividend
it's the same as if they say
they're repurchasing my shares.
Because it's--repurchasing my
shares, if they do it for
everybody, doesn't mean
anything.
I'm getting--we're all
lowering--all of our shares are
going down by the same amount.
So, that's the basic insight in
Modigliani and Miller,
that share repurchase and
dividend are really
interchangeable;
it's just all a conceptual
difference.
This kind of took people by
surprise.
It's kind of--it should be
obvious, I'm making it so
simple.
I could write some mathematics
to try and--but I think it's so
simple and obvious.
You just have to keep
remembering that all that
matters for a company--for you
as a--your interest in a company
depends on your shares divided
by the total number of shares.
In a stock repurchase,
if they repurchase everybody's
shares--the same proportion--it
doesn't affect that ratio.
So, you don't care what the
letter says--whether it says
dividend or stock repurchase.
Why would a company want to do
one or the other?
Well, Modigliani and Miller are
leaving the room;
they say it doesn't matter.
If you ask them why a dividend
payout policy has
changed--there's a famous Miller
quote--he calls it a "neutral
mutation,"
as a reference to evolutionary
biology, that sometimes
mutations are neither
advantageous nor deleterious.
The genome starts piling on
mutations that mean nothing;
that's how they date the
branches of the genome,
by looking at the number of
neutral mutations.
He said all this--this thing
that I have up here--well the
previous slide,
showing the dividend earnings
ratio--it's just cultural;
it means nothing because,
to some extent,
what's not shown in that
diagram was the stock
repurchase.
I want then finally to talk
about Modigliani-Miller and
debt.
Now, I didn't talk too much
about debt yet.
Before I talk,
I just want to say one more
thing about Modigliani-Miller
and dividend--irrelevance of
dividends.
There is a possible correction
to be made due to taxes.
When Modigliani and Miller
wrote, there was a differential
tax rate between dividends and
capital gains.
It was--Modigliani and Miller
said back then--this was thirty
or forty years ago--that
companies should really not pay
dividends because dividends were
then taxed at a higher rate than
capital gains.
You don't want to give your
shareholders taxes.
You should, in your fiduciary
duties as a board member,
be trying to help them lower
their taxes.
It doesn't say that in the
state law but that would be
inferred as a duty.
So, you would avoid paying
dividends and,
therefore, switch to share
repurchase as your method.
It took decades for
Modigliani-Miller to kind of
sink in.
As you can see,
part of the reason why the
dividend-earnings
ratio--especially in more recent
years,
since 1990--has been declining
is that corporations were trying
to somewhat ease the tax burden
on their shareholders by doing
repurchase instead of dividend.
However, that all changed in
2003 with the Jobs and Growth
Tax Reconciliation Act of 2003,
which cut the rate of taxation
of dividends to 15%--the same
rate that capital gains are
taxed.
There is now no
preference--well it could
be--there are lots of
complexities in the tax law but,
basically, dividend policy
really is irrelevant now.
If there's no tax advantage to
one over the other it is
completely neutral.
The other thing that I want to
say about Modigliani and Miller
is about corporate debt.
I talked about a company as
having only shares outstanding,
but they also have debt
outstanding.
So, a company can borrow money.
If a company borrows a lot of
money it's called "leveraged."
Leverage is measured by the
debt-equity ratio.
Now, D here stands for debt;
a minute ago I was using Div to
stand for dividends.
They both start with the letter
D but they're very different
concepts.
The debt of a company is the
amount of money it owes either
to banks, or to bond holders,
or to note holders,
or commercial paper holders;
these are fixed incomes.
In other words,
they are not shares in the
company.
When a company becomes
leveraged, it then becomes
riskier.
The company becomes riskier
because the earnings they have
available after paying interest
on the debt,
or repayment of principle of
the debt, is what they have
available for dividends.
If debt becomes high relative
to their revenue stream then the
company is in a riskier
situation.
There's another
Modigliani-Miller theorem about
debt, which is about debt
irrelevance as well.
That sounds funny,
but in a sense,
that is--we have to define the
sense in which it's irrelevant.
It certainly isn't irrelevant
to the price of a share.
The more money a company
borrows the more risky the share
becomes.
It's just like if you buy a
house and you buy - a lot of
people are very leveraged now.
They might put only 10% down on
a house, so you buy a house for
$300,000 and you put $30,000
down;
that's an investment of $30,000
but it's highly risky because
you are very leveraged when you
only put 10% down.
Suppose the home price falls by
only 10%--in fact,
that's what's been happening
lately.
Your $30,000 down payment is
completely wiped out because you
were leveraged.
You bought the house for
$300,000;
you sell it for $270,000 that's
exactly what you owe,
so you have nothing left.
So, leverage brings risk.
Boards of directors have long
agonized over how much to borrow
and different companies seem to
have different cultures.
For example,
Microsoft has avoided borrowing
any money and they don't believe
in debt, so they are not
leveraged.
But other companies get heavily
indebted and then they can go
through big problems.
It's a very common item of
discussion at board meetings
about how much should our
company borrow,
so they seek advice from
financial experts.
They call in Modigliani and
Miller and ask,
how much should we borrow?
What do finance theorists say?
In the extreme case,
where we disregard taxes and we
have to disregard some other
problems, we get the same
answer.
Modigliani and Miller said,
we don't care what you do,
do whatever you want--it
doesn't matter.
This is what I want you to
think about on the problem set.
Or, maybe speaking about the
answer to the questions on the
Problem Set #4 will help you to
think this through.
The simplest way to see
Modigliani-Miller debt
irrelevance is the following:
a company--if you wanted to buy
a company,
you could buy only the shares,
or equity.
Incidentally,
did I ever--equity equals
shares or stock,
so when I talk about
debt-equity ratio,
I'm talking about the ratio of
the value of the company's debt
to the value of all of its
stock.
If you wanted to buy a company
up and own it yourself
completely, you could conceive
of buying all the shares in the
company.
There are ten million shares
outstanding--I'm going to buy
ten million shares.
But in a sense,
I don't really own the whole
company yet because the company
owes money.
What if I wanted to buy the
whole kit and caboodle--the
whole operation?
I should be buying all the
equity and all the debt as well,
right?
If the company issued--if I
really want to own it and I have
no--I really wanted to be the
tycoon and this is my baby,
nobody else can get in my
backyard;
I can do whatever I want--you'd
have to buy all the equity and
all the debt.
Otherwise, if you don't buy all
the debt, you still have a
problem because those debtors
can go after you because they
are--they're not shareholders
but they have rights and they
could come in and say,
we don't like what you're doing;
we're going to sue you because
we think that you're doing
something contrary to our
interest as debtors.
If you really want to buy the
company, you buy up all its
equity--all of its shares--and
all of its debt.
The basic insight about
Modigliani and Miller debt
irrelevance is that,
in the absence of taxes or any
other special thing,
the real value of the company
is going to be unaffected by
whether they finance by debt or
by equity because the real value
of a company is determined by
the cash flow that they generate
by the business they're doing.
So, they are selling widgets or
whatever and making money--the
value of the company is the
present value of that cash flow.
If you want to buy the company
you have to buy up all the debt
and all the equity.
From the standpoint of a buyer
of the whole company,
what do I care how the
ownership of the company is
divided up between debt and
equity?
I have to buy them all anyway,
so I don't care whether
three-fourths of my money goes
to debt or one-fourth of the
money goes to debt.
I just want to know the bottom
line;
how much do I have to pay for
the whole company?
The debt irrelevance theory
says that it matters for the
price of a share what a company
issues--how much debt it takes
on--but it doesn't matter for
the value of the company.
There's almost an arithmetic
relationship theory that they
put forth.
I'm not going to go through
their numbers but the value of
the company, as a whole,
is really determined by
something outside of finance.
Again, we have to qualify the
debt irrelevance for taxes.
So, companies might be
concerned with the fact that
debt is tax-deductible for
corporations on their corporate
profits tax but dividends are
not.
According to Modigliani and
Miller, if you add taxes to
their debt irrelevance
proposition,
it means that companies will
want to borrow a lot and the
real advice they would be giving
to Bill Gates is:
what's the matter with you?
Why aren't you borrowing money?
It's tax deductible,
whereas dividends are not.
That would mean that companies
should try to push their
debt-equity ratio up as high as
possible given that theory.
On the other hand,
if they do so,
they may be courting
bankruptcy.
If the company gets too
leveraged then there's too high
a probability that the company
will fail and there are costs to
bankruptcy.
The other qualification is
bankruptcy costs.
A company, according to
Modigliani and Miller,
has to weigh their tax
considerations against their
bankruptcy costs and get an
optimum debt-equity ratio out of
that.
It is an insight that
Modigliani and Miller are
offering the corporations that I
think they often don't see that
the real issue in the
dividend--both the dividend and
the debt policies--are really
taxes and nothing else.
The last thing,
I just wanted to say--I wanted
to mention the theory of
dividend payout given by John
Lintner;
it's called the Lintner Model
of Dividends.
I'm saying that,
unless tax considerations
intervene, dividend policy is
really irrelevant for a firm.
Maybe Merton Miller is
right--these things are "neutral
mutations" and changes in
dividend policy are meaningless.
But how do they actually do it?
How do boards and their
committees decide how much to
pay out in dividends?
John Lintner was a professor at
the Harvard Business School,
who, decades ago,
did a survey of people who
decide on dividends and asked
them, what goes on in your mind
and what do you think about when
you decide on dividends?
He had a long discussion;
they said millions of different
things--it's very hard.
People who decide on dividends
are facing a complicated issue.
One thing that Merton Miller
(sic) distilled from it was that
people on boards,
who decide on dividend payout,
are very focused on the price
of a share and they're worried
about investor reaction.
Boards always want to keep
their price of a share up
because if it starts to decline,
the company could become a
takeover target;
it's viewed as a failure etc.,
etc.
They talked a lot to him about
investor psychology.
In a sense, I'm terminating
this lecture with another
triumph for behavioral
economics.
When we think about the theory
of dividend or debt we end up
with irrelevance--it doesn't
mean anything--but the
companies' boards talk about it
incessantly and it seems to
matter a lot to them.
If you ask them why it matters,
they say, well it's pretty
obvious--it's all their investor
psychology that we have to deal
with.
They say things like this:
if we pay a dividend,
then they're going to start
expecting that.
And if we don't pay a dividend
once, then they're going to say,
what's wrong?
As long as we never start
paying a dividend,
then we're just a young company
and nobody asks any questions.
Then we start paying a dividend
and then if we ever have to cut
it, we're in big trouble.
The newspaper reporters will
start calling,
why did you cut the dividend?
You said, you didn't call us up
when we weren't paying any
dividend and now we're still
paying more than we used to,
why all this alarm?
They said--one of the lessons
they were told is,
never cut a dividend unless you
do it as a--you could do a one
time only dividend.
Say, we're just doing this once
and don't expect it again.
But if you start paying regular
dividends, then you better keep
doing them or people are going
to conclude that something is
really wrong.
They told him that if earnings
go up--we try to keep a target
payout ratio--but if earnings
suddenly shoot up,
we're not going to increase our
dividends right away because
that would set too high an
expectation and we don't want to
have to cut it.
So if earnings go up a lot,
we'll raise our dividends,
but only part of the way up.
The model that–I better
get it right--the Lintner Model
says that there's a target
payout ratio--that's the Greek
letter tau (τ) and that's
the target payout ratio.
That ratio may have been higher
in the nineteenth century;
it's gradually trending down,
but it's a slow-moving thing.
So they want to payout
something like 40% of their
earnings as dividends and plow
the rest back into investing
inside the company.
Then there's another parameter,
rho (ρ),
which is the adjustment--rho is
between zero and one.
It's how fast they adjust to
the target.
So the Lintner Model then says,
the change in dividends,
Div_t - Div_T-1
= ρ
(E_t - Div _T
– 1).
That means that if your rho is
from a positive number like
half--so if earnings is above
dividends you increase your
dividends,
but only by half as much as
would bring it up to the target,
if rho is a half.
That means there's a gradual
adjustment of dividends to
earnings.
For example,
if this is tau and this is
earnings--if your earnings were,
say,
flat and suddenly increased
like that, they wouldn't believe
this increase at first,
so the board would decide to
adjust only, say,
half way up.
Now I'm plotting dividends.
The dividends were down here at
half the earnings and then you
would gradually adjust them up
to half the earnings again.
That's because they don't want
to ever be caught cutting their
dividends.
Also, if the earnings drop,
they don't want to suddenly do
a crash cut in their dividends
either,
so they're always sluggishly
adjusting toward the target
payout rate.
Lintner showed that this simple
model--the Lintner
Model--explains the behavior of
companies pretty well.
Next session is Friday with
Stephen Schwarzman and I'll see
you then.